[Music]
there is no machine in the world
today that can be a whole device
with a single wire, it is only
them through that ancestral knowledge
of tissues, that dedication that they manage to
make such complex structures
[Music]
my name is French  but dental I am
a pediatric
interventional cardiologist and I am dedicated to manufacturing
medical devices to treat
heart disease
thanks to these devices we can
cure up to 60 percent of
diseases without opening the chest
the device advances through this catheter it
reaches where the heart defect is
reconfigured  in that place if it is the
heart defect
I was here in Bolivia it had the
technology it did not have machines and
people have come to me and have asked me if
they were willing to
help us
the ladies who come to us
are Aymara and have the ability to
do  the tissue in their blood is 60 or 70
percent of Bolivians
come from these people  s original
that is fine as well as the little thing those
ladies in the beginning have been
our patients
we have had some patients who we
have not been able to treat their children
we have applied the solution to them and they
have already worked with us
[Music]
my name is veronica  and Balboa they I am
a weaver
my mother taught me to
protect since I was a child
we who have the devices
help save lives
the little ones it is about three hours in the
big ones it is a day and a half and also in the
weavings because a lot of patience
dear love of weaving they
are more than  50,000 patients that we have
treated, because the knowledge and
systematization that engineers bring,
plus the skill and art of these
artists, is what produces these
devices.
For me, it is beautiful that these
ancestral fabrics together with technology are
saving children. For me, it is a miracle
[  Music]